le palais de l'Élysée cet après-midi un
carousel d'autocar remplace le
traditionnel balai des voitures
ministérielles la scène a été dressée
dans l'immense salle des fêtes de
l'Élysée où ont lieu les conférences de
presse présidentielles le spectacle est
de qualité et la pourvedette Henry
Salvador et Mireille Mathieu monsieur le
Président Madame mesdames Messieurs mes
chers petits amis j'ai le plaisir de
vous présenter maintenant mon grand
copain vre am
[Musique]
h après le spectacle le président
Pompidou s'adressera à ses jeunes
invités qui venaient d' tener en cœur
avec Henry Salvador et M Mathieu la
fameuse chanson le travail c'est la
santé si le travail c'est la santé il
faut croire que je ne travaille pas
beaucoup car je suis un peu gripé
aujourd'hui a dit le président Pompidou
à ses jeunes invités